what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we are going to
watch Brooklyn Nine Nine season 4
episode 4 today right yeah that's
the one leave a like you know what to
do leave that like let's just get to it
it's not a secret meeting Jake it's an
intervention the tips have to go what
why Jake we're worried about you and
you look very stupid come on guys I
think they're kind of cool retro are they
gonna shave his head I'll admit it I went
too deep down there in Florida before we
just chop them off would anybody like to
say some final words no that was one word
that counts thank you Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me it's
worth it me and Jake are chip buds what
you know what I do see it it's bad it looks bad I
always wanted to frost my tips
back when I had short hair I
it's an old new demographic for me to conquer
Sergeant Jefferson a word what is wrong with
everyone I'm worried our night shift morale
problem has gotten worse yeah you think my
wife says when I get tired I get night
sassy night sassy hearing problems much
it's my responsibility to fix this
I'm going to brighten the Mood by
telling a few jokes try this one officers
I don't care for cheese I'm a curd Majin
you're too tired for humor
it worked for me ever since I moved the day
shift I'm happier healthier my stepson gave
me my debit card back oh Hank is happy and
confident everything's off oh no we're in
the upside down that's right I'll be back in 40
minutes what where are you going I have to get
some pens then why are you putting your jacket
off the nearest pen store is seven blocks away
and it doesn't open until 9 A.M you really
think you can lie to me no ha you're lying
to me right now you do think you can lie to
me yep second under police tape I miss this
oh my God how low can you go okay so I am smoking
ah Jacques roses on cigarettes a
habit he picked up from a prostitute
Marseille but why do all your characters
because they're living life all right
move over to the second case smash bracelets but
then we hear a sound and I yell at least and I
know what that means because I'm French but I ask
you to repeat it in English just to be sure yes
flick your cigarette using the cane he's in
the cane this is awesome voila dang great
news everyone we just got our first lead on our
first case on my first night back proving once
and for all that absolutely nothing has changed oh
geez but we're gonna work until it's done right I
mean that's how we do it yeah I just like to
be home as soon as nikolaj wakes up so I can
make him breakfast goddamn kids not a problem we
will be home by sunup just like a couple of Sexy
Twilight vampires I am Robert Pattinson I bought
the third to do a bat you're an insult to the
books can I get you something coffee tea you know
what we're in a bit of a hurry can you run this
DNA for us well of course sorry not many people
stopping by at night sometimes it makes you like
hahaha not exactly The A Team at this
hour a team are you guys talking a team
I love that show I could download it we
should binge it this is gonna be fun yep
totally excited to watch five full seasons
of Television run the DNA for us first kind
of feels like you're prioritizing work
over our friendship because I barely
know you fine message received love when a
plan comes together I was in the bathroom
I'm having stomach problems oh okay all right nope
should have been there I don't have to hear it
I've been researching ways to raise
morale and I found an interesting
article in a scientific journal
according to a recent study the
physical act of smiling can improve
your mood I've heard this many times
now you're a try
big smiles bigger bigger great
Hitchcock this isn't working out
as well as I'd hoped time for the
next level forced laughing ha ha ha
now we just got to pull his files from records yep
then we bust him and we'll be done with plenty of
time before nikolaj wakes up Nicolas Nicolas
yeah I said it Nicolas Nicola almost Nicolas
Nicolas I feel like I'm saying it you know
what it doesn't matter that baby's gonna ruin
your friendship hi can we get this file please
we're in a bit of a hurry oh absolutely honey
laughs
oh yeah
there we go oh my glasses there I
was gonna fight for oh sorry dude
I don't know how to get onto the system
I'm a temp may I great let me just get
over here oh good lord that is porn oh is
that not allowed it is not I'm just tabs
got a lot of them the hell she said she
was in the bathroom again nah she hasn't
been to the bathroom since 8 27. what also
ew come on Hitchcock huh who are you Texan
definitely gonna catch this guy before
setup and you will be home to see your kid
oh Jake come on in collage look who it is
remember Jake what a grown-ass kid story
he is real I know you're with your kid but I
checked the file in her perps last known address
is like two blocks from me I really want to go
Jake but I'm here alone with nikolaj Genevieve
does get back for three hours so let's just take
him with us now that's crazy or is it just crazy
enough to work do it stinks you got to watch
him it's really messing everything up I mean
that came out wrong I love that you have a son
it's not messing everything up it's just messing
up our ability to solve the case and have fun you
know what I mean I'm a nice guy I'm in the right
it's an after work hang just trying to turn up
uh maybe we should just name our
favorite sailing knot the bow line
how about some tunes it's a good one or
favorite sailing sorry you're all miserable
but guess what so am I I'm exhausted all the
time I never see my husband the late night
NPR programming pure garbage I saw you earlier
you weren't in the bathroom you were on a park
bench playing on your phone yeah you left me to
do everything well I thought you were pooping
oh Rosa crying don't know what to do
we put away figures three weeks ago my mentor
should have been back by now we had plans to
meet on that park bench once the coast was
clear he hasn't shown up maybe he's deep
undercover or he doesn't remember who he is or
maybe he's dead wow Jones Tomcat Smith Smith
slow down this isn't fair should have
shot him yep I need your Subaru I need
to commandeer this vehicle it's a crossover
whoa It's a crossover SUV and you can't have
it I'm a cop so addition now this is
Schmidt's mom's car and I'm more scared
of her than I am with some two-bit thugs
I'm not a thug I'm police okay the name
one law don't kill people that's me I set
the bar too low look can you please just
but who cares about the state's capital is this
the same safe character right yeah she
said Schmitz new girl's Canon I guess
chasing a criminal your soup is not important you
took an oath to Serve and Protect that applies to
my soup you know that's not what the oath is about
you're making a point you don't even believe it
damn it
you tell me which is worse my thing very clearly
my thing that's crazy I love when it shows do that
the night shift stinks stinks like a butt and I
will do everything in my power to make sure we get
back to the day shift what are we standing around
for put some Zeus on already I want to get wild
you angry at Boyle for having a kid no I'm just
mad because I'm working the night shift and I
have to use a cane and yes the one thing I
could always count on no matter what Boyle
being there for me is also gone what do you say
we let day shift low hang take a crack at this
I guess I haven't actually spent that much
time with nikolaj yet nikolaj man am I
seriously about to take emotional advice from
low Hank you know you want to Compadre do it
go to him listen to good Matt Walsh I'll do
your paperwork and if you ever want company
on that bench I'm there thanks I would advise
against it though if he does come back things
are gonna get real raunchy real fast like
I do a lot of licking that's probably a
decent experience I want to be there yep
I apologize for what well I kept talking
about how I wanted everything to go back to
normal but if that actually happened this
little guy wouldn't be here or is he big I
don't know what size kids are supposed to
be or anything about kids really I think maybe
that's part of the problem it doesn't matter
I got a present for nikolaj thanks Jake a truck
just like this almost killed me today uh kiss me
oh my God this is a dream come true I gotta
get my phone I gotta film this oh but then
I'll miss it oh but I want it forever ah but I
should say in the moment don't forget oh my gosh
no Boyle hang in there respect mad respect Matt
Walsh respect I've seen every episode of New Girl
really yeah twice dang I like new
girl but I left off maybe season four
I saw what I feel like people agree were the the
best seasons oh they saw three episodes years
ago oh dude it's a good show I liked it I just
remember watching what's his name Jake come uh
uh oh Jake Johnson Johnson Schmidt yeah
no uh Schmidt is Max Greenberg I don't
know I don't know how I remember
[__] I don't care I don't care
uh I just remember for some reason the name
Schmidt always stood out to me yeah yeah yeah
but I've only seen like three episodes and that
was many many years ago like when it first hit
Netflix or something go back and re-watch
I feel like you would like it nah maybe
what is his name damn not now now I'm gonna
have to IMDb a second thing oh what they're
okay so I wanted I want to know there the guy
who was the tech looked exactly like a dude we
did improv with for like a brief glimmer in
time and I want to know if it was really him
but uh all right we'll put the video on pause yes
but uh that character is not listed at all on IMDb
so so we all lost something today yeah day it
was time dalen if that was you comment below
well what'd you think I enjoyed it it wasn't maybe
the most uproarious episode of the bunch but you
know I mean you have to have a transition
of getting back in the swing of things and
even though it's not like the most serial episode
coming out of a very serial Trio of episodes it's
still you know I like I like the personality of
this one and everyone's sort of yeah being cranky
and and what the night shift is doing to people
I thought that led to a really funny bit with
with good Matt Walsh and uh and two you know Jake
having to come to I've spent the season feeling
like nicolage wasn't real so I was like cool I
like that and I like this like little the little
ways in which he has to accept that you know life
has moved a little bit since he was gone and honey
collage was a baby uh uh you know that's a fair
thing to think I didn't think he was real at all
so I didn't bother to think what kind of child
he wanted didn't he get a phone call when he was
um in prison as a doctor that the
baby was coming or something like that
wasn't adopting I think it was adoption oh that's
right yeah because he was he had a inhospitable
environment yeah so he is right he couldn't uh
okay yeah that's right that makes sense I still
thought they were adopting a baby who adopts a
grown-ass kid you know they're a waste of time
if you're thinking of doing it don't do it you
can't really condition them the way you want to
make them your little slave that way you can
convince them to your biological child you know
what I mean guys that's the point that's the point
yeah yeah yeah you know this is an interesting
question at home tougher and smarter yeah if
you're an orphan if you're an orphan watching this
and you're above the age of six get it together
you know together man you're gonna be much more
badass it's gonna be easier to pick up chicks
yeah totally yeah you'll have a nice rebellious
wrong side of the tracks backstory you know yeah
this makes me wish I was an orphan that's right
all cool superheroes are orphans Billy Batson
true I'm just saying man Bruce Wayne's the same
being an orphan is uh it's a gift it is a gift
it is an asset it is a power to be wielded and
um if you suspect you're adopted don't try to find
out because that means your parents did well sure
if they if they got you at the right age yeah
what I mean yeah totally um you can't convince
someone you pull them out they already have a
brain that's been developing for a few years no
I don't know anyway Let's uh stick that on the
wall put a pin in that and come back to the orphan
yeah we'll we'll unpack that some more that's the
season I would love to adopt um that's like one of
the most lovely gifts you can do I get I think
how would you know you know would you possibly
know that's one of the most lovely gifts you can
do because I feel like there's some clothes ever
in your life you I am an impulsive person you
would be surprised you do you know something are
you friends with someone who adopted and you were
there for the process yes to be like oh my God
they just adopted a child I'm gonna go meet this
child totally and I I vetted the child myself so
I was like I know his personal experience it was a
terrible thing it is a torture to put Upon a Child
to pluck them and it is a difficult psychological
process and I'm just telling you it's just it's
not worth it why yeah all you're doing is inviting
them I want to give a kid a life of awkward jokes
people will make without realizing they're being
offensive yeah especially if you adopt outside of
your race you want to try and get them to look
like you that way there's no question about it
yeah so I'm just part of Me Part of Me Now is
sitting here going what is the real ethics of
that unless you're rich you know then you can
give them a really something something really
special if you're rich and then Plus public wise
that looks great it is a good it's probably a text
write-off too it's a good tax write-off and uh
makes you look humbling not like all these other
celebrities yeah I'm waiting until the channels of
two million Subs then adopting and dude you could
have them monetize that kid too my guests start a
kid Family Channel make the kid edit those videos
monetize the [__] out of that child ways to do
it ways to adopt yeah um that financially benefit
you but uh we again another time the the yeah I
thought the episode was really fun yeah oh John's
uh begrudging attitude towards this episode is
no it was really fun it was one of those episodes
where I wasn't like defying every joke but I loved
the mood the falling because I don't know like a
good guffaw like you know that's an actual
word falling I've never heard that word okay
yeah that's a common word it definitely
already used in many sentences totally
over I mean I guess uh it probably showed
up a lot in Harry Potter or something
did it in the books I would imagine maybe those
were the most consistent uh you know the most
consistently I would have dipped into the same
literary voice and thus I could imagine maybe
I maybe it was used there and uh damn but if I
it's it's an older word it it's a it's a more
Antiquated term for laughter it's more Arcane
if you will a bit archaic even retro vintage
oh yeah there we go it's lost
until we got there stupid
um anyway yeah uh I thought that the episode was
um so it was not a filter fish those bloopers boy
it was not a Gravity Guy it was not Gravity Falls
China nice to meet you yeah Nick Miller that's
his name I didn't even need to get the Google
search It's Jake Johnson's name and the new girl
he's Nick Miller and I really cared anyway
continue on so falling yeah I think the Amy
storyline was nice I felt like it had something
to do with Jason manzukas that was a it was kind
of heartbreaking I like whenever we get to see a
more sensitive inside of Rosa feeling far between
but you know when you're reminded that Stephanie
Beatrice can cry on camera the mark of any good
actor aren't many good reactor too it's funny
because in that moment I was going oh wow she's
she's really committed to this but I'm like I
guess it wouldn't be good if you wasn't I guess
like because it's a sitcom you're surprised but
yeah she was great that was funny I think Holt
being trying to be Captain who's trying to be like
a funny fun fun leader in the department at uplift
morale was hilarious but uh Andy Samberg to me
it's still like really is like the Andy Samberg
the Jake can hold [__] it really there's so many
ways it is the Jake and Holt show and it's just
like his antics of just escalating and trying to
keep you under control and his difficulty growing
up is it's a consistently funny thing to me and
yeah I have plenty of friends now I've had kids
and uh cousin who has a kid not adopted
not adopted the way you should do it and
you heard it here folks so if you
were considering it now you know
um and um you know if you find offense of
that sorry but if you're someone who actually
is adopted you're probably not offended because
you have thick skin and if you don't know you're
adopted then you're none the wiser to anyone
subconsciously you know around the family you
know something's all right I know I'm a Targaryen
I'm I'm definitely a Targaryen and a Valerian
um they're not adopted that's true I'm not
work not an example no no it did not work
that joke I'd take it back stricken
it from the record your honor it's so
um oh my God what are we talking
about we were talking about
um the Jake and Holt Dynamic yeah whatever it's
fine and then to end funny enough they didn't
did they really interact at all in this episode
like I thought that was no no I think there was
tensions on set and they wouldn't allow them to
interact in the same room keep them a part or
a fight's gonna break oh yeah but it was it
was really fun and nice to get some of that
as much as there is the tension of nicolage it
was nice to get some of that classic uh Samberg
and and Le triglio together Le trulio however
you say his name get get some Jake and Chuck
yeah next one's the Halloween episode though it's
right I'm excited it's gonna be a heist I assume
do you know this already well isn't that the
tradition isn't always the Halloween Heist of
some kind or is the heist a different no it's
it's a Halloween Heist I'm sticking in my guns
as Canon all right guys listen uh we did our part
we're done so thanks for being here Zoe Deschanel
showing up is nice my mind was doing some work
there I was like oh is this like a celebrity guest
star or was she not a celebrity yet and then it
took me a few minutes of minutes uh like moments
to be like wait a minute Schmidt New Girl that's
the same one yeah and then when I was about to
say that I saw your face looking weird and I was
like oh is that same one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was like a one-two punch it was like whoa wait
like this is a little late for for special guest
star Zoe de Chanel whoa whoa wait what this
is context of a holy other show but I guess
they were both on Fox that's smart so that's cool
because new girls on the west coast right so like
maybe there was an arc at the time where she's
visiting New York I can't remember or is it in
they live off like the beach don't they I
don't know I I gotta see it again I gotta
watch the show it's about like three guys trying
to banger uh at some point and then it graduates
at least one of them is trying it's trying to
bang everyone and then one of them is trying
to romantically you know over much time
bang her I don't see the appeal I'm sorry
or or of the premise of New Girl
uh you know manic pixie to go watch I've
never seen 500 Days of Summer but go watch
that I'm sure yeah I get it bubbly and
quirky but also it's pretty she plays a
scientist in The Happening no a teacher Mark
Wahlberg's a scientist much more believable
I'm going to teach you all about physics okay
anyway um why are you eyeing my lemon drink
I know buddy I'm sorry for everything
that's ever happened in your life
things could be much worse to be honest what's
in the cat all right guys we're good we're done
Brooklyn nine nine